[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 78 société à magazine dédié
aux question qui vous interpelle et ce
qui nous a interpellé en ce 22 octobre
et bien ce sont les chiffres de la
sécurité routière dans le département et
notamment le nombre des de tués des
décès qui concernent le plus souvent les
deux roues et puis cette semaine est
consacrée aussi au aux personnes âgées
c'est la Semaine Bleue alors faut-il
limiter l'âge de conduite B on tentera
aussi d'y répondre ce soir en plateau
avec moi deux invités jean-y petit
bonsoir de la prévention routière et
Jean-Luc prévau bonsoir de la Fédération
des Motards en Colère faut plus dire
motards en colère faut dire autre chose
mainten les de toujours en colère
d'accord et puis nous aurons Simon Midal
par téléphone de l'Automobile club
association il s'avère que Monsieur
Midal est venu de Paris en voiture et il
est bloqué il est bloqué sur la route
alors d'abord donc les chiffres hein je
l'ai dit c'est toujours froid et un pl C
les chiffres mais ça révèle aussi une
certaine
réalité au 14 octobre 2013 le
département des Ines a enregistré 40
tués depuis le début de l'année il y en
avait eu 38 sur la même période en 2012
et par parmi ces 40 tués on dé nombre 16
motocyclistes alors une première
réaction jeanluc prév 16 motocyclistes
tués sur 40 c'est beaucoup quand on sait
que forcément les motards sont pas les
plus nombreux sur la route voilà mais il
faut aussi pondérer ce chiffre hein
pourrait dire aussi également que les
piétons par exemple par rapport au
nombre de gens qui traversent sur la
route il y a pas eu beaucoup de tué par
rapport au nombre de piétons qui
traversent la route hein donc il faut
pondérer bon si on est s'il y a autant
de de de de tuer sur la route c'est
aussi parce que notre c'est la fragilité
hein le motard est fragile c'est
incomparable avec un avec une
automobile en plus de ça malgré
tout sur le chiffre à peu près la moitié
ne sont pas responsables de leur décès
alors 65 % voilà 65 % ils sont
responsables des accident et le reste ce
sont les automobilistes voilà mais ça a
été aussi euh c'estàdire vous me dites
65 % 65 % étai d'ailleurs responsabl de
leur accident c'est ce que nous a dit la
préfecture voilà de des motards ou de de
l'ensemble des
motards mais l'année dernière c'était
probablement 50 et inversement ça
pouvait être 40 vous savez
malheureusement on n pas à quelques
sarmer euh si toujours toujours toujours
mais maintenant on n' pas toutes les
clés pour pour améliorer la la sécurité
routière he du motard où il faudrait
[Musique]
peut-être se pencher sur la formation
peut-être un peu plus
d'information détecter surtout savoir on
va enarler effectivement de la formation
parce que ça à mon avis c'est peut-être
la clé du problème mais je petit une
réaction sur ces chiffr alors 40 tu sur
la route c'est beaucoup c'est plus qu'en
2012 il y a eu un weekend
particulièrement plus meurtrier ce
weekend effement plus qu'en 2012 sur
l'ensemble du pays les chiffres sont en
baisse et dans notre département
malheureusement c'est en hausse pour ce
qui concerne les les motards je voudrais
juste rappeler un chiffre les motards
les de rou motorisé donc motard et
cyclomoteur ça représente à peu près
2,5mi % du trafic mais 25 % des tués on
voit donc qu'il y a une
surreprésentation énorme et je pense pas
que Jean-Luc préau me contredira la moto
c'est intrinsèquement dangereux
foncièrement dangereuxectivement c'est
ce que c'est ce que dis pré forcment est
moins bien protégé on n pas de
carrosserie la seule carrosserie c'est
le casque et puis sur quatre rou on est
quand même plus stable que sur deux
alors je dis pas bien sûr qu'il faut pas
faire de moto mais comme le dit Jean-Luc
prévud il faut quand même savoir que
c'est dangereux prendre les précautions
et être bien formé pour ça alors
justement la formation c'est le mot qui
qui revient autour de cette table est-ce
qu'il y a assez de formation on sait
maintenant qu' il y a une obligation ou
pas de passer une formation pour les
possesseurs de de PER parmis auto qui
voudrait pouvoir utiliser des 125 cm C
est-ce que il y a une formation de 7 he
qui est préconisée est-ce que c'est bien
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin est-ce
qu'il faut avoir un permis moto même
quand on veut conduire une
125 puisque vous me regardez je vaisier
alors c'est pareil moi je pense que ça
va dans le bon sens ça va dans le bon
sens c'est sûr plus il y a de enfin plus
il y a de formation si la formation est
bien faite ça va dans le bon sens parce
que une moto même 125 cm C c'est pas
comme une voiture moi j'aurais le droit
avec mon permis B que j'ai passé il y a
quand même longtemps de conduire une 125
je ne le ferais pas sans sans être aller
dans une dans une Autoécole et pourtant
j'ai le droit mais donc il faudra
peut-être aller plus loin mais en tout
cas ça va dans le bon sens c'est quoier
plus loin pour vous je là je laisserai
peut-être jeanluc en parla mais je
depuis le début de l'année depuis le
mois de janvier on a instauré des des
Nou nouveau permis moto et d'ailleurs le
permis am le tout premier pour le cyclom
moteur donc tout ça va dans le bon sens
pour responsabiliser les les gens enfin
les les les conducteurs il y a peut-être
d'autres choses à faire encore mais mais
on progresse alors faut faire aut
j'arrive petit qui vous passe la parole
aujouri faut fa plus je suis un exemple
justement je suis un
transfuge de la voiture par la la 125 et
la moto j'avais déjà à peu près 5 6 ans
de conduite automobile donc à ce
niveau-là il y avait pas de souci mais
j'ai appris à mes dépend la pratique de
la moto c'està-dire de tomber tomber sur
des choses que je ne connaissais pas
parce que là j'avais pas du tout de
formation maintenant la la formation du
motard est quand même assez copieuse he
il y a deux épreuves plateau il y a une
épreuve sur route il y a le code
euh tout ceci s'est fait pour obtenir on
va dire un
diplôme peut-être que tout ce qui est
par contre annexe et qui permettrait
éventuellement de d'améliorer la
sécurité par exemple ne pas fréer de la
roue avant quand c'est mouillé parce
qu'on tombe par exemple bah c'est pas
c'est peut-être dit dans la formation
mais c'est zappé par le par le stagiaire
on va dire parce que bon voilà c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a son permis on
pourrait repasser encore une un autre
stage per voilà bah oui parce qu'on
autre après il y a l'expérience qui
commence à à à venir et donc on pourrait
effectivement améliorer encore la la
conduite alors la fameuse formation des
7hur pour ceux qui ont qui peuvent
conduire un deou qu' un permis auto qui
conduise un deou cette formation elle
est obligatoire il faut pouvoir
justifier d'un certificat quand on se
fait contrôler vous en pensez quoi cette
formation 7h elle est suffisante elle
est elle est ça sera toujours
insuffisant mais elle est c'est déjà pas
mal elle existe faut 7 he pour conduire
un de roues elle existe elle existe
avant elle n'existait Pasin donc voilà
c'est c'est déjà tout l'avantage de la
de la chose quoi ou je voudrais faire
une petite pause qu'on puisse écouter le
le préfet des ivelines puisquil il est
lui-même revenu sur ces chiffres de la
sécurité routière qui ne sont pas bons
pour nombre de tués et qui ne sont pas
bons pour pour les deux roues on va
l'écouter il a aussi un début peut-être
de de solution on écoute euh on doit y
travailler on doit essayer de faire
prendre conscience aux motocyclistes que
leur comportement est parfois dangereux
bien sûr il y a toujours ou le plus
souvent une un véhicule qui un autre
véhicule qui est engagé dans ces
accidents néanmoins c'est souvent le
comportement du motocycliste qui qui qui
cause qui cause le danger par ailleurs
il y a la situation des trois roues des
secouteurs à trois roues où là il y a on
constate des défauts de maîtrise de ces
engins par leur propriétaire il n'est
pas impossible que nous envisagions à
titre expérimental et pédagogique des
opération sur la route pour essayer de
faire prendre conscience aux
motocyclistes que le fait de doubler euh
les véhicules sur la file de droite peut
présenter un danger donc nous allons
faire ça dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent alors voilà le préfet des
ilines qui fait référence à l'article
très précisément
r414-6 du code de la route qui réprimand
le dépassement par la droite vous en
pensez quoi j'en prév il faut
DESC enfin quand il parle du déplacement
par la droite il doit s'agir du du REM
ce qu'on appelle le remont fil euh sur
des sur des voies plusieurs plusieurs
tout le temps pardon voit tout le temps
ah oui bien sûr mais attendez essayz de
rester entre deux voitures c'est pas non
plus c'est sécuritaire he il suffit que
l'autre s'arrête pas derrière vous êtes
mal aussi le sandwich c'est pas bon non
plus hein donc il fait référence à ça
euh mais c'est en ce moment c'est en
cours de c'est en test pour justement
améliorer la chose la position d'MC dit
c'est en test pour améliorer la chose
c'estàdire améliorer le enfin pour
savoir si le remont de fil on va le
effectivement le l'adopter pour la
FFMC le remont de fil n'est valable que
jusqu'à une vitesse de 60 km/h au-delà
on intègre les fils euh sinon euh il
faut avoir un différentiel de 10 à 20
km/h par rapportcord donc il faut que le
motard regarde son compteur après déjà
quand il est à à 60 ou 70 km/h sur le
périphérique parisien qui où en gros les
voitures sont à 15 km/h c'est déjà
rapide he quand même ou oui mais
justement on est contre hein c'est le
différentiel 1020 et je peux vous
garantir par expérience que s'il y a une
manœuvre d'un automobiliste vous le
sentez tout de suite
euhême oui oui non mais ça ça se voit
hein tout de suite vous le sentez hein
et ça vous permet quand même d'éviter un
accident pour ou contre alors
l'autorisation pour les motard de fameux
le remil ouai le remont fil qu'on qu'on
voit qu'on voit non le Remon fil nous ne
sommes pas opposés au remont fil à
condition bien évidemment que ça soit
encadré par le code de la route avec des
des des des dispositions techniques que
sur lesquelles je vais pas m'étendre
mais c'est une pratique qui existe et je
comprends bien les les motards qui
l'emploie c'est pour aller plus vite
dans les embouteillages donc c'est c'est
à titre personnel j'ai déjà vu des je
devrais peut-être pas le dire mais j'ai
vu des moteurs de la police nationale le
faire alors oui mais c'est pour
l'instant c'est une pratique tolérer
pour l'instant ce qu'il faut c'est
l'encadrer et le le gros avantage de
l'encadrer c'est que ça sera dans le
code de la route et on y revient encore
ça sera dans la formation dans les
auto-écoles aussi bien pour les motards
qui apprendront ce remontefil que pour
les automobilistes aujourd'hui c'est pas
dans la formation par c'est pas toléré
donc c'est pas dans la formation bah on
apprend un certain nombre de choses je
connais pas le détail particulier par
exemple vitement la porte qui s'ouvre ça
c'est quelque chose qui est dans la
formation du du motard heureusement
c'est pas tous les jours qu'une porte
s'ouvre devant vous donc je là je dois
avouer que je n'ai pas le détail ça fait
longtemps que j'ai passé moi mon
permisend pas à faire le on apprend à
passer entre des des poteau et des
chaînes c'est assez c'est c'est pas
large on apprend aussi à passer sur une
poutre donc on est un peu dans cette
configuration le remont de
fil ça concerne les motards et aussi les
les automobilistes ils le savent déjà
bien sûr qu'il peuvent être rrapés par
des par des motards mais si c'est
enseigné dans les auto-écoles et dans le
code de la route dans dans les tests du
code ça ne peut être que bien ça ne peut
être que bien et la répression à tout
prix est-ce que c'est une bonne chose
parce que là on entend dire le préfet on
va faire des des contrôles plus
fréquents est-ce que c'est une bonne
solution bah pour les excès oui oui les
gros excès oui certainement maintenant
pour les petits excès je trouve que
c'est un
ça va trop loin quoi euh ça sent les
gens n'y croient pas n'y croient pas
parce qu'on a l'impression que on va
leur prendre du fric hein c'est c'est
leur réaction et s'ils pensent comme ça
bah ça peut pas marcher voilà je voulais
aussi une réaction sur les fameux
scooters TR roues dont parlait le le
préfet dans dans l'interview vous dites
ah euh ou on vient justement parre une
al du coup c'est peut-être une catégorie
de pilotes qui sont peut-être pas
forcément des des motards à guuéri et et
des vrais motards dans l'âme j'ai envie
de dire mais plutôt euh éventuellement
des va être un cliché maisô le cadre
supérieur qui veut aller vite travailler
donc il prend son son scooter TR roues
en se disant sur avec une trois roues je
suis stabilisé bah il s'avère que non
quoi oui non euh ça se comporte
exactement pareil qu'une moto quand ça
roule si ce n'est que quand on s'arrête
il y a il y a il y a un système qui
permet de verrouiller la la position et
ce ce système se déverrouille dès qu'on
commence à rouler donc non ça ne protège
en rien de plus les et ils sont souvent
assez puissants d'ailleurs ces fameux
bah oui oui il faut avoir le il faut
avoir le permis moto pour construire
certains scooters hein euh pas toujours
euh la formation des fois des 7urs
suffit si les scooters 3 roues ah bah
sauf sauf s'il dépasse les fameux 80 cm
maintenant je vous laisse je vous laisse
parler ça on parlait tout à l'heure mais
il y a effectivement des
constructeurs qui ont trouvé l'astuce de
d'élargir l'empattement pour que les
engins ne soient plus classés dans la
catégorie motocyclette mais dans la
catégorie tricycle avec laquelle il
suffit d' d'un simple permis B tel que
le mien pour conduire ces engins qui
peuvent atteindre 500 cm³ or pour les
gens qui seraient tentés par ça ça n'a
rien à voir avec des voitures ce sont
bien c'est ce sont ce sont bien des
motos mais ça ça vous vous l'expliquez
c'est que le scooter 3 rou peut devenir
un 500 cm³ c'est quand même voilà ça va
vite sur la route et on peut le conduire
avec un permis moto sans avoir aucune
connaissance d'un de roues comment ça se
fait que ça soit pas réglementé ça c'est
réglementé mais le c'est réglementé mais
non non c'est pas ça je dis il y a une
norme et les constructeurs jouent avec
la norme ils se mettent à 1 cm auudessus
de la norme lame alors il faudra
peut-être revoir les normes au niveau
européen c'est c'est c'est
probable mais les les les constructeurs
ne ne trichent pas ils profitent de de
toutes les de tout le système et ça
c'est un vrai danger quand même sur la
route hein on les voit ils sont assez
hésitants on les sent assez hésitant je
ne sais pas si c'est plus dangereux
qu'un qu'un de roues c'està-dire je p je
pense pas que les statistiques je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez soit on est
suffisamment de recul pour savoir si le
tris roues est plus dangereux que le que
le de roues à priorie c'est quand même
plus stable mais on a comme vous l'avez
dit à l'instant des gens quand même
moins expérimentés qui passent
directement de la voiture à au TR roues
pour aller au boulot sans grande
expérience enfin je précise juste que la
formation des f fameuse formation des
7hur obligatoires pour ceux qui veulent
conduire des 125 pour le le 3 rou c'est
plus cher B si la formation est plus
cher à mon avis c'est qu'il y a plus de
choses à apprendre ou elle est un peu
plus un peu plus coûteuse je vrais
passer à un autre sujet maintenant c'est
les les radars on est en plein dans
l'actualité puisque depuis lundi il y a
des les fameux nouveaux radars embarqués
donc dans les voitures qui pourront
flasher les voitures qui passent qui qui
arrivent enfin en gros on pour être
flashé dans tout les sens en tout cas
pour ceux qui font des grands excès de
vitesse he je le précise il y a 19
départements qui sont concernés en
France dont le département des ivelines
il y a aussi ces fameux radars dont il y
a un qui va apparaître sur la 13 en
direction de poissi qui pourra à la fois
flasher soit les limitations de voiture
soit les limitations de de camion vous
en pensez quoi de ces
radars si c'est pour
effectivement imprimer les grands excès
il y a pas de souci on est absolument
pas contre maintenant si c'est pour
c'est pour alpaguer toutes les tous les
usagers de la route qui dépassent qui
font des petits excès de vitesse de 10
20 kmh je crois que voilà on est on est
pas poursol pas pour mitiger ou il faut
savoir où ils sont placés il faut
savoir c'est pas trop alors il y a de
fortes chance qu'il soit utilisé sur des
axes très
fréquentés si c'est sur des autoroutes
c'est encore là où les les accidents
sont les moins nombreux donc c'est un
peu bizarre comme on sait pas où ils
sont on on connaitt les marques des
voitures je ne les citerai pas les
marques des voiture on é on ét dé voilé
vous en pensez quoi de C de ces radars
là je ne partage pas je ne partage pas
la position de la
FFMC il faut de la prévention bien
évidemment puisque tout le monde sait
enfin tout le monde ne le sait peut-être
pas pas mais la la vitesse et la
deuxième cause de mortalité sur la route
la première c'est l'alcool l'alcool tout
compris enfin pour les motos comme pour
les voitures c'est la la deuxième cause
de mortalité sur la route la prévention
ne suffit pas et ben il faut de la
répression et 20 kmh pour moi c'est pas
un petit excès de vitesse on va pas
faire de calcul mais la différence de
freinage entre 50 km/h et 70 km/h est
quand même importante
donc nous sommes nous pour les radars
puisque les chiffres le montrent quand
il y a des radars il y a moins
d'accidents les statistiques le montrent
donc évidemment c'est pas l'idéal le
mieux serait que qu'il ait pas besoin de
radar mais je veux dire je vais être
très pragmatique si les gens doivent
payer des sous pour améliorer la voirie
et et éviter que les autres payent des
impôts bah moi j'aime autant que ça soit
les les gens qui commettent des
infractions au côte de la route plutôt
que les autres plutôt que les autres une
dernière question euh avant de passer à
la à la limitation d'âge ou pas pour la
conduite euh limiter la vitesse sur les
départemental à 80 km/h au lieu de 90
km/h c'est le comité d'experts du
Conseil national de sécurité routière
qui a rendu un avis qui le préconise
àors 10 km/h en dessous est-ce que c'est
à ce point-là ça peut à ce point-là
réduire le nombre d'accidents je petit
alors nous nous nous ne pensons pas
qu'il faille réduire de façon
autoritaire sur toutes les
départementales la vitesse de 90 à 80
mais il y a des endroits
incontestablement où 90 c'est trop
rapide j'étais en Corse cet été en
vacances les départementales limité à 90
mais moi je dép
60 c'était limité à 90 quand même je
peux vous dire il y avait des gens qui
qui faisaient des 90
aut mais non il faut il y a des endroits
qui méritent très certainement d'être
limité à 80 des département ental mais
il faut pas systématiser bien sûr et
laisser le soin au préfet de d'étudier
au cas par cas mais nous ne sommes pas
pour une généralisation de la limitation
à 4 ça va faire encore une limitation de
vitesse supplémentaire on a déjà des
nationales comme la 10 par exemple qui
traverse les ilines où il y un coup
elle est à 110 un C 90 70 ah bon vous
nous assurez que ça va être harmonisé
tout ça parce que c'est un peu
comp 90 8 90 oui sur les départementales
malgré tout je vois peu de contrôle
quand même euh moi je suis un adepte des
départementales parce que les lesut je
m'ennuie sur les autoroutes donc benah
je vois malgré tout peu de peu de
contrôle donc que ça soit 80 90 c'est
pourtant là que sont les accidents oui
bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est ça le le le
souci c'est que c'est peut-être pas
assez contrôlé parce que malgré tout
aussi sur en départemental il y a aussi
moins de passage puis il faut savoir
aussi que globalement la plupart des
départementales sont utilisé par des
gens des locaux et ces locaux savent
très bien où sont les les radars et
cetera donc ils passeront à des vitesses
tout à fait tout à fait normal devant
ces radars et donc c'est complètement
inefficace quoi voyez c'est le chien qui
se m la queue là c'est votre av on va
faire une petite pause avant de parler
de la dernière la dernière thématique
sur la limitation d'âge comment réduire
le nombre d'accidents sur la route et
bien c'est la question que nous sommes
allés poser aux habitants de
Saint-Quentin on écoute leur réponse
surveiller alcool surveiller la vitesse
et aussi voir que
les les pièces
ne font pas n'importe quoi limité le
nombre de voiturees un peu de tout de
vigilance de gens qui traversent un peu
à droite à gauche sans regarder
éventuellement et puis déjà si on a un
véhicule être mettre du sien quoi bah
reprendre le vélo tout simplement il
faut toujours chasser l'alcool au volant
et faire attention avec les jeunes
conducteurs qui sont un peu fous au
volant les hommes particulièrement la
responsabilité de chacun c'est un peu à
nous de de pas prendre la route pour un
jeu de se dire qu'on n'est pas tout seul
queil y a aussi du monde avec nous et à
nous de faire
attention alors maintenant on va changer
de thématique on va parler de la
limitation d'âge pour la conduite et on
a je crois au téléphone Simon Midal
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
délégué francilien de l'Automobile club
association vous auriez dû être en Plou
avec nous vous êtes bloqué sur la route
absolument malheureusement j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu éviter l'autoroute et je me
suis fait coincer dans une petite RU
avec les ppiers de et voilà et voilà il
va il vaait venir en transport en commun
monsieur Midal
mais compliqué aujourd'hui bon alors on
va parler de la faut-il imposer une
limite d'âge pour conduire je rappelle
ce ce triste fait d'hiver samedi une
femme de 84 ans qui a pris l'autoroute à
contresens dans le Cher elle est décédée
ainsi que la conductrice qui l'a percuté
alors vous allez me dire il y a pas que
des personnes âgées qui prennent
l'autoroute à contresens et vous aurez
raison euh malgré tout pour
l'association club pour l'automobile
club pardon euh est-ce que à votre avis
il faut limiter l'âge pour conduire ce
qu' veut dire un moment donné on arrête
faut arrêter bon alors à d'utre
questions je réponds non limité l'âge
sûrement pas parce qu'il y a des gens
que nous connaissons tous à 60 ans qui
ferait bien arrêter de conduire et
d'autres qui à 85 ont une conduite
exemplaire sans accident et sans aucun
problème je crois que c'est au
conducteur à l'automobiliste d'être
assez assez correct dirons-nous et assez
se connaître pour pouvoir prendre les
décisions opportuns il y a avec ses
médecins ses pharmaciens la possibilité
de connaître son état donc à ce
moment-là c'est à chaque automobiliste
de prendre ses responsabilités en
sachant que s'il n'est plus hte à
conduire bah il arrête et nous
connaissons tous des exemple autour de
nous de gens qui ont arrêté de conduire
il faut encore il faut encore pouvoir
avoir le j'allais dire le le courage et
peut-être la lucidité c'est pas facile
quand on vieillit de se dire je ne suis
plus apte à conduire ça c'est pas simple
mais à votre avis est-ce qu'il faudrait
un examen médical malgré tout alors
comme dans certains pays il y a un
examen médical mais alors je vais vous
répondre par exemple dans certains pays
comme l'Italie ou
l'Espagne je vous assure et je peux vous
prouver que vous allez voir un médecin
pour un certificat médical le médecin
vous le donne immédiatement il y a même
pratiquement pas ça fait rire nos
invités en plate ouais donc ça peut ne
pas être bien bien bien sérieux tout ça
Jean pe non c'est pour ça il faut
responsabiliser si vous voulez
aujourd'hui notre action à nous à LAAC à
l'association notre action elle est
simple elle est réellement de
responsabiliser les automobilistes et en
tout que ce soit sur la vitesse que ce
soit sur les problèmes de voiture que ce
soit sur les pneus que ce soit sur
effectivement la conduite il faut
responsabiliser le conducteur et c'est
ce qui arrive de plus en plus lorsque
nous pouvons le réaliser et il y a des
essais par exemple en Alsace
actuellement il y a un club qui s'est
ouvert des personnes séiores
pour justement la conduite et ils ont il
ils se contactent ils sont en relation
avec l'association sur place dans le
cadre de la zas et je peux vous dire que
ils ont effectivement une conscience
parfaite de leur responsabilité
d'automobiliste oui je vais poser la
question à à nos invités en plateau
jeanque petit alors vous est-ce que il
faut limiter l'âge est-ce qu'il faut un
examen médical est-ce que vous partagez
le point de vue de simonou je partage le
point de vue de Simon Midal limité l'âge
il l'a parfaitement dit c'est non et
l'examen
médical comme il l'a dit également c'est
pour l'instant pas une une solution qui
fait ses preuves dans un certain nombre
de pays d'Europe c'est obligatoire pas
uniquement d'ailleurs pour les pour les
personnes âgées ça dépend les pays mais
statistiquement il est pas prouvé que ça
apporte un avantage que ça apporte un
bien et enfin j'ajoute que en France je
ne suis pas certain que nos médecins
soient prêts à prendre cette
responsabilité oui parce que ça sera à
eux de dire sera eux de dire le cou prè
oui vous pouvez conduire non vous pouvez
plus conduire avec toutes les dérives
don monsieur Midal a parlé et qui
pourrait très bien arriver chez nous
aussi évidemment Jean-Luc préve
excusez-moi excusez-moi d'intervenir je
voudrais simplement préciser qu'il y a
un moyen qui est très simple qui
s'appelle les assurances parce que les
assurances au bout d'un certain nombre
d'accidents et notamment pour les
seigneurs refuse de les assurer et là il
y a
véritablement
intermédiaire extrêmement utile dans le
cadre justement des seurs jeanl pr je
suis d'accord aussi pas de
limitation faut la personne sache
éventuellement si elle est en état ou
pas de pouvoir conduire par contre il y
a quelque chose dont on oublie beaucoup
c'est la on parle d'alcool de drogue
mais on parle pas souvent de médicaments
ou et beaucoup de en France il paraît
que nous sommes des gros consommateurs
de médicaments ou notamment dans typ
presseur je dis pas que les personnes
âgées prennent plus d'tiépresseurs que
les autres mais il y a certains
médicaments qui effectivement
nécessitent une vigilance accrue sur la
route voilà il y aura peut-être une
étude à faire dans cette direction pour
savoir vraiment quelle est la portée de
de cette consommation de médicaments
ouais tout à fait c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai parlé d'ailleurs des
pharmacies d'accord tout à fait bah
comme ça vous êtes vous êtes tous les
trois d'accord on va finir cetteci SIM
mavoir répondu à nos questions on va
finir cette émission avec une autre
question du jour on est allé dans les
rues toujours de Saint- Quentin cette
fois-ci pour demander pour faut-il
imposer une limite d'âge pour
conduire je pense que ce serait tout à
fait normal quand même parce qu'on
arrive à un certain âge on a plus les
mêmes facultés on a plus les
mêmes réflexes que que quand on est plus
jeune oui oui parce que certaines
personnes arriv à un certain âge
où maîtrisent pas
la tout ce qui est visuel l'audition et
c'est selon aussi le les facultés qu'on
a encore Laib bilit les mouvements les
gestes enfin les réflexes tout ça c'est
sûr passer des tests c'est sûr sans
interdire c'est vraiment la personne a
envie de conduire pas forcément une
limite d'âge mais en tout cas un suivi
plus important plus régulier il faut
surtout une surveillance médicale quel
que soit l'âge parce que des plus jeunes
qui sont sous médicen qui sont dangereux
mais des personnes âgées qui sont très
dangereuses effectivement à partir
certain âge il faut vraiment surveiller
de
façon bien régulière à mon avis
voilà le mot surveillance effectivement
pour la conduite des personnes âgées
merci en tout cas à vous deux d'être
venu en plateau pour nous parler de de
sécurité routière je rappelle que c'est
la Semaine bleue en plus en ce moment et
qu'il y a plusieurs opérations qui sont
menées pour les personnes âgées
notamment à spectacle interactif jeudi à
La Verrière où il y a encore l'école de
conduite française qui organise des des
des formations pour les seniors cette
émission est terminée merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez-vous dans
15 jours pour un nouveau une nouvelle
émission du 78 société à bientôt
[Musique]